i don't know it was like i i damned it
didn't want to do it you know what i
mean like it's like this is more work
than i thought you just get exhausted
with doing every dance that you don't
know you know what i'm saying like it's
one thing to
you know
be a kid and learn how to walk once man
but it's like if somebody tried to teach
you how to walk 10 different ways
as a 30 30 year old you looking at them
like hey bro this looks better and feels
better so i'm gonna do this like you
know i mean like that's what your mind
wants to say and it was just like
all the small technicalities it was just
like to get my habits to break it was so
difficult i i didn't think it was that
difficult and i'm lucky that danny
stayed
stayed in the practice right uh i mean
rehearsal space with me for as long as
she did because we did get a lot of
practice in but
um by the time we did get the trophy
though
it was worth it so
no it was definitely it was definitely
worth it man um was it like a different
type of challenge for you obviously
being a
athlete um coming from
you know being one of the
however many people are in the nba was
that 370 people in the nba something
like that one of the 370 best athletes
in in the in the world when it comes to
basketball to go into the dancing world
like how much of a different challenge
was it for you
um
it was
it's a big adjustment it's uh
i say
basketball is already kind of like
poetry in motion so to speak like you
have to make smooth movements uh
with your athleticism and i think
that was like my biggest advantage when
um
when the weeks progressed it was like
danny started leaning on you know what i
was good at you know we started doing
lifts we start
uh
uh just doing things every week that we
start calling them moments but it was
like
we would have these moments that you you
feel something you don't really you're
not really just watching the show you
just saw it like the us thing it was
like people felt that [ __ ] like they
felt like we was really in the movie
like we was really trying to remind them
of the movements um
and play on the tethered version of
ourselves and it was like doing that i
think
really boosted us but the the
the adjustment from basketball to
dancing
i think basketball is already pretty
much like we got to do it is kind of
like dancing right like i'm doing the
wrong one right like something like that
ain't nothing but a finish over there
right right here you know what i'm
saying that's a finish so that's that's
a reverse
that footwork is me getting around the
screen you know what i'm saying like
it's similar it's just i gotta
make it fun so i'm like running around
the rehearsal space like okay euro step
here
five six seven eight okay that's you
know what i mean like that's how i was
remembering i'm sitting here telling
myself basketball terminologies as the
footwork